>> BREAKING NEWS ON
CAPITOL HILL, TEXAS CONGRESSMAN
LOUIE GOHMERT HAS TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID-19.
HE WAS SCHEDULED TO TRAVEL TO
TEXAS WITH THE PRESIDENT THIS
MORNING AND IN THE ROUTINE
SCREENING TO BOARD AIR FORCE ONE
HE RECEIVED THE DIAGNOSIS.
AND HE ISN’T BEEN KNOWN TO NOT
WEAR A MASK AROUND THE CAPITAL
END IT’S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
HE WAS AT THE HEARING YESTERDAY
WHERE ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR
APPEARED AS THE KEY WITNESS.
WE ARE JUST GETTING THIS, AND WE
AWAIT MORE INFORMATION AS WE
HAVE CALLS AND EMAILS OUT TO HIS
OFFICE.
>> Trace: A COUPLE THINGS WE
SHOULD NOTE IS THAT
LOUIE GOHMERT IS 66 YEARS OLD,
HE WILL BE 67 ON AUGUST 18.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE
IS AGAIN SOMETIMES WEARING A
MASK ON CAPITOL HILL, HE’S DONE
INTERVIEWS IN RECENT DAYS WHERE
THEY HAVE ASKED HIM ABOUT HIS
RELUCTANCE TO WEAR A MASK AROUND
CAPITOL HILL, AND HE SAYS THE
REASON THAT HE DOES NOT WEAR A
MASK IS BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN
TESTED ON A REGULAR BASIS AND IF
HE DOES TEST POSITIVE, AND THE
CHAIRMAN JERROLD NADLER DIP TEST
DIES AND CRITICIZED A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS FOR NOT WEARING THEIR
MASKS AND LOUIE GOHMERT WAS NOT
AMONG THEM.
HE HAS BEEN PRONE NOT TO WEAR
THE MASK IN RECENT DAYS AND
WEEKS AND MONTHS.
LET’S BRING IN OUR CHIEF
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS WHO ACTUALLY
CONFIRMED THIS NEWS.
AND THE NEXT DAY YOU CAN PAP
TEST POSITIVE FOR IT, AND THE
NEXT DAY TESTED POSITIVE AND HAD
TO TAKE 14 DAYS OFF.
ANYONE WHO COMES IN PROXIMITY TO
THE PRESIDENT AND WE ALL GET
TESTED FROM CORONAVIRUS AND,
SINCE AIR FORCE ONE WAS LEAVING
IN THE 9:00 HOUR, AND IT
HAPPENED THAT HE CAME BACK
POSITIVE.
WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE MEDICAL
USES, IS THE RAPID TEST.
BECAUSE HE TESTED POSITIVE FOR
THE SOURCES, AND HE WAS REMOVED
FROM THAT TRIP TO ODESSA AND
MIDLAND WHERE THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING SOME FUND-RAISING THIS
AFTERNOON AS WELL AS OFFERING
MORE HELP FOR THE BATTERED OIL
AND GAS SECTOR.
TESTING POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS
USUALLY BRINGS WITH IT A
CONVALESCENT.
THAT IS ANYWHERE FROM TEN DAYS
TO SOMETIMES, DEPENDING ON HOW
ILL YOU GET, IT COULD BE A
NUMBER OF WEEKS.
THE TIME THAT I SPENT WITH HIM
IN VARIOUS SITUATIONS AND, THE
CORONAVIRUS ILLNESS COULD BRING
WITH THAT PARTICULARLY
DELETERIOUS EFFECTS.
AND IT, CHAIRMAN JERRY ANOTHER
ADMONISHED A COUPLE OF THE
REPUBLICAN MONITORS AS WELL AS
JIM JORDAN.
WHAT’S IRONIC IS THAT WHEN
NADLER ISSUED HIS VERY STRIDENT
ADMONITION WHICH IS NOT LIKE
WEARING A MASK AT ALL.
THE WHOLE IDEA, IT STRIKES A LOT
OF DEBATE AND SOMETIMES A LOT OF
TENSIONS AMONG PEOPLE.
AND NOT LONG AGO HE WAS A
EJECTED FROM A CONVENIENCE
STORE.
THE CONFRONTATIONS ABOUT MASKS
ARE OFTEN ESCALATING INTO
SITUATIONS THAT PEOPLE WOULDN’T
NORMALLY EXPECT THEM TO DO.
OF COURSE NOT SEEING ANYTHING
LIKE THAT HAPPENING IN DETROIT,
BUT STILL’S ATTENTION SOMETIMES
RUN HIGH.
HE’S NOT ON THE TRIP TODAY, YET
TO HEAR ANYTHING OFFICIAL FROM
HIM AND AS YOU POINTED OUT, IF
YOU CAME DOWN WITH CORONAVIRUS
DISEASE YOU WOULD NOT SEE HIM
WITHOUT A MASK.
ONCE YOU GO THROUGH A
CONVALESCENT PERIOD, YOU HAVE